(light music)
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Are you guys ready to play?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Studeis suggest
which sibling is more social,
suggesting they might
be better at parties.
- Most social? Okay, fine.
They used to tell me when I was three
I would grab people at weddings and just
dance with them out of nowhere.
- He did that last week, too.
- Oooo, we all said oldest.
- Taking that party title.
- I'm not saying I'm the life of the party
in all situations.
- Well, you do love a good party.
- I do love parties.
- [Voiceover] So, it's
actually middle children.
(buzzing)
No one guessed right.
- Oh, okay.
- I think so.
- Only Megan.
- A study found which sibling
tends to be a perfectionist.
- I don't think we even
have to discuss this one.
- No.
- We just all know.
- Want to say it all together?
- One, two, three.
Middle child.
- Middle child.
If the science is science,
it would trend this way.
- Oooo, we said the -
- Since when?
It's you.
For instance, you were cooking those like
egg wraps from that cookbook.
She didn't get it right the first time.
She made it the next day.
You have plans to make it again.
- [Voiceover] Yep,
Emily, you guessed right.
(bell rings) It is oldest children.
- Oh, you were right.
- I knew it.
- Maybe I'm just trying
to not be a perfectionist.
- Which sibling has been shown to be
most empathetic of the family?
- Oldest, for sure.
- How it is.
I think he's the most emphathetic.
- I was basing it on my -
- He knows it.
- It's true.
- Oh.
- I definitely think
that Jessica's the most
empathetic of all of us,
because you're very sweet and kind.
- You always send a followup text.
- I use those emoji things on the text.
- Oh, yeah, the emojis?
- I like those.
- Exactly.
- [Voiceover] Yes, that's right.
Younger children have been shown
to be the most empathetic. (bell rings)
- Yay!
(upbeat music)